[Música]
ah
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y los acompaño en
este programa esta vez para hablar de su
majestad del tenista suizo roger federer
que anunció su retiro del circuito
profesional a sus 41 años de edad
federer acumuló 20 grandes slams e hizo
parte de la que ha sido considerada una
época dorada para el deporte para
conversar sobre el retiro de este grande
nos acompañan a pablo amalfitano
periodista especializado en tenis y
quien trabaja para los medios página/12
y el gráfico y también catalina castaño
ex tenista profesional colombiana
entrenadora deportiva y además
comentarista muchas gracias a nuestros
invitados y también a nuestros
televidentes a quienes les recuerdo
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen sus preguntas y
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter y instagram y
facebook en donde no se encuentran como
arroba france24 guión bajo ese y arroba
angel ago efe 24 mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta de ese numeral el debate efe 24
en youtube se pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming
saludamos a quienes se conectan con
nosotros vía podcast no olviden que
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
están disponibles en app el podcast en
spotify deezer y también en junín
entremos en materia después de la salida
de serena williams la leyenda suizo
roger federer anuncia que pondrá fin a
su ilustre carrera se refiere a una
lesión de rodilla que le ha afectado
durante los últimos tres años y además
ha dicho que el mensaje de su cuerpo ha
sido claro que a pesar de todos sus
esfuerzos debe reconocer sus límites
se mantuvo en lo más alto del ranking
mundial del tenis durante casi dos
décadas ahora después de luchar contra
una lesión de rodilla roger federer dijo
que la copa ley verde la próxima semana
en londres un torneo que él mismo creó
será su último evento profesional
también conozco las capacidades y los
límites de mi cuerpo y su mensaje para
mí últimamente ha sido claro tengo 41
años he jugado más de 1500 partidos en
94 años el tenis me ha tratado con más
generosidad de la que jamás hubiera
soñado y ahora debo reconocer cuando es
el momento de poner fin a mi carrera
competitiva roger federer tenía sólo 19
años cuando venció a su ídolo
sampras en la cancha de wimbledon en
2001 batió récord ganando el torneo ocho
veces y se ganó un lugar especial en su
historia
roger por donde empezamos echaremos de
menos tu presencia en nuestras canchas
pero todo lo que podemos decir por ahora
es gracias por los recuerdos y la
alegría que has dado tantos en total el
tenista suizo ganó 20 títulos de gran
slam pasó un récord de 237 semanas
consecutivas en el número 1 de la atp
llegó a compartir cada vez más
protagonismo con el serbio novak
djokovic y el español rafael nadal con
quien tiene una relación particular
querido roger mi amigo y rival ojalá
este día nunca hubiera llegado ha sido
un placer pero también un honor y un
privilegio compartir todos estos años
contigo aunque empezó siendo un jugador
revoltoso y propenso a decir malas
palabras
cr desarrolló una reputación de
deportista y de hombre de familia él y
su mujer tienen dos pares de gemelos que
lo acompañaron durante años en el tour
el anuncio del jugador se produce justo
después de la retirada de serena
williams por lo que el tenis ha perdido
a dos de sus más grandes esta temporada
y comienzo con catalina un cordial
saludo para usted y vamos con la primera
pregunta que tanto impacta catalina al
deporte y al tenis el retiro de federer
bueno la verdad es que es algo triste de
que se retire pero creo que era el
momento de
llegar no es fácil haber jugado por
tanto tiempo y ahora tener tantas
lesiones eso no es fácil para ningún
tenista y más un profesional y una
persona como fue roger federer que fue
es la leyenda del tema es otra es el
primer pero pesa la vez es entendible
que ya era la hora de retirarse por la
lesión que estaba bien bueno no podía
durar eternamente como usted lo está
diciendo pablo ustedes qué opina sobre
este impacto que genera esta noticia que
llega a esta semana y qué bueno que
genera muchísima tristeza entre los fans
pero también entre sus colegas
bueno si hay que decir que el impacto
obviamente es mundial es un impacto muy
fuerte pero hay que tener en cuenta
también que es una noticia que estamos
todos esperando no desde el año pasado
cuando federer se resintió de la lesión
de la rodilla derecha ya todos estamos
esperando a ver si qué te pasaba a que
volvía a federer porque esa era una
pregunta muy importante también un
interrogante que estaba dando vueltas a
que volvía a federer si volvía a jugar o
volvía a despedirse y bueno la respuesta
llegó esta semana federer vuelve para
despedirse en su torneo con su gente y
en londres que también es una ciudad muy
importante para él donde ganó seis
campeonatos de maestros claro era una
noticia esperada y sin embargo no cree
usted que había también la esperanza de
que no se diera pablo porque pues
después de las intervenciones de rodilla
que se hizo federer en los últimos
tiempos pues esto lo que muestra es un
deseo de poder volver a estar en forma y
poder dar algo más de millas en una
carrera que ya de por sí fue muy largo
fueron 24 años presente en las canchas
ganando y además dejando momentos
inolvidables
seguramente veremos en el futuro en
documentales en la posteridad de esas
grandes jugadas de federer y todavía nos
sentiremos sorprendidos de ese gran
juego que no se nos dio por tanto tiempo
si me parece que primero hay que
destacar que obviamente se esperaba por
un lado esa ilusión esa esperanza que
tenía tanto la gente como los
especialistas como los periodistas como
la gente de su entorno era porque
básicamente porque es federer siempre
fue un diferente no solamente por el
juego sino por el cuerpo él ha sido un
privilegiado por la manera que tiene de
jugar por la armonía con la con la que
siempre se movió dentro de la cancha e
históricamente fue un cuerpo que no
sufrió lesiones entonces eso generaba
también la esperanza pero la realidad
también marcaba que si federer volvía
volvía para despedirse en un año y
planeaba también despedirse en wimbledon
del año que viene
no era no era una carrera que se pudiera
extender mucho más sobre todo por la
manera de jugar él siempre ha tenido que
reinventarse al paso de las generaciones
han aparecido jugadores juegos lo mejor
es poder cada vez más fuerte con más
potencia con más físico y él siempre ha
tenido que reinventarse ha atacado mucho
más los últimos años para para no
desgastar su cuerpo
en un momento es un combustible que se
termina y bueno el cuerpo de federico
basta la realidad que obviamente es una
despedida muy impactante para el deporte
no solamente para el tenis pero bueno es
una cosa que que se esperaba se sabía
que iba a ser así y el cuerpo de feder
por más armonioso que pareciera iba a
tener un final no pero por supuesto y
catalina usted estaba hablándonos
también pues del impacto que ha generado
esto de lo triste que ha sido pero
también nos destacaba mucho que es un
buen momento para retirarse no solo por
su estado físico sino por toda la
carrera que nos deja atrás cree usted
que es de cierta manera providencial que
federer anunció su retiro muy poco
tiempo después de que alcaraz se corona
como número uno del mundo o el más joven
en la historia del circuito profesional
un buen relevo diría usted
si angela yo creo que esto yo ahora lo
estaba analizando y sin
saber que al canal es el próximo la
próxima figura ya es número uno y que
viene es también jóvenes de atrás yo
creo que un buen momento para para
acceder es dar un paso atrás
y decir bueno darle paso a las
generaciones llega un momento en que el
cuerpo no duda ni mentalmente porque uno
sabe que tiene que dar mucho más con los
jóvenes y másters alcaraz que es el más
joven que ha ganado un grand slam
entonces sabía que le tocaba tocar
luchar la muchísimo más y el cuarto ya
no respondía bueno pero también en
catalina llegó un momento durante esta
carrera de federer en el que nos
preguntamos cuándo iba a darse este
relevo porque era casi que un partido
entre tres entonces eran los títulos
siempre definiéndose entre djokovic y
nadal y federer y bueno al parecer el
panorama finalmente está cambiando
finalmente pues hay un relevo
generacional
y aquí por eso quisiera preguntarle ya
mirando hacia atrás como cambio el tenis
con el estilo de juego de federer porque
fue muy dominante hasta que apareció una
figura como rafael nadal y después como
no le ambos son menores que el de cinco
o seis años
y pues hay que destacarlo es que de las
310 semanas que federer detuvo el puesto
número 1 286 de esas semanas fueron
semanas seguidas como fue este cambio
que generó el que federer trajo el juego
bueno pues yo pienso que hay que
destacar lo tenístico pero también hay
que destacar la presión como manejo
mentalmente durante tanto tiempo
pues mantenerse como número uno
como siempre se vio un federer con buena
postura y cualquier nada que siempre se
les dio como
no están involucrados en el escándalo
siempre han sido caballeros dentro y
fuera de la cancha yo creo que eso eso
eso va a quedar para la historia
creo que si viene el relevo ahora de los
jóvenes pero va a ser muy difícil lo que
ellos marcaron como el sobretodo federer
en esta en este aspecto
pablo y su opinión
a mí me parece que si consigues con
catalina las emociones son muy
importantes de manejar es federer manejo
las emociones como ningún otro quizá en
la historia sobre todo
bueno
si lo escuchamos y lo escuchamos y nos
perdimos por un momento pero ya está
otra vez con nosotros
nos decía que me parece que está bueno
destacar la diferencia entre esos dos
momentos el feder dominante que estuvo
en la cima del ranking entre 2004 y 2008
hasta que apareció no nadal y las
emociones que él supo gestionar como
supo reinventarse para tratar de superar
a nadal primero y después a djokovic ha
ganado grandes títulos también con ellos
dominando y eso también me parece que
hay que destacar
federer es una persona y un jugador que
se ha podido transformar ha podido
adaptar su juego a las generaciones al
estilo de juego del momento y ha ya
transformado en tenis en ese sentido ha
jugado en el fondo ha jugado hacia
adelante ha jugado contra los más chicos
contra los más grandes me parece que hay
que destacar eso es un jugador que se ha
enfrentado a tenistas de nacidos en el 5
de cada distintas pero 60 a los 2000 es
un jugador que es lo muy longevo y ha
ganado cosas
grande y eso me parece que es un dato
muy destacable las emociones son muy
importantes en tenis quizás más
importante que el físico y que los
golpes del 1 al 100 del mundo casi todos
le pegan muy fuerte a la pelota y le
pegan bien y juegan y tienen estrategia
y tienes táctica y trabajan con equipo
con un preparador físico pero entrenador
en la diferencia está en la cabeza y
federer también con nadal y djokovic en
esa era dominante han sido destacables y
ya que está hablando de eso pablo pues
quisiera ir al tema que nos tiene a
todos rascando los la cabeza y
preguntándonos cómo tenemos que
decidirnos se va el mejor de todos los
tiempos teniendo en cuenta toda esa
historia y todas esas características
especiales que usted nos menciona es el
gol
y a mí me parece muy difícil acelerar
primero porque la historia es muy larga
la realidad que no no sé si alguien está
capacitado para decir si federer o tanto
nadal como djokovic también son más
grandes que root ley pero que vivió en
board o que jimmy connors la verdad que
la historia es muy larga
federer se va sin el record slams porque
tienen 1 - que dio concha y dos menos
que de nadal se va sin el récord de
semanas número uno al mundo porque tiene
310 contra 373 de djkovic y se va sin
otros récords pero si tiene tiene una
aceptación en la gente en los
aficionados en el público en general en
los jugadores que ha superado el hecho
de los resultados deportivos y me parece
que hay que separar creo que federer si
está en esa discusión del más grande de
todos los tiempos es porque genera un
cambio de paradigma en el tenis es otra
cosa excede los resultados
hace poquito gaudenzi el presidente de
la atp dijo claramente que se va el
jugador que trajo más aficionados al
tenis él generó una expansión y una
masividad
en este deporte que posiblemente dure en
el futuro dos años hay jugadores que han
jugado al tenis por feder por ejemplo si
participas sabe que tiene el revés a una
mano y que juega al tenis hoy pasas a
federer y por eso lo despidió como lo
despidió me parece que más allá de los
resultados
lo que tiene federer para para pelear en
ese puesto de ser mejor de todos los
tiempos es más espiritual que
deportivo
catalina su opinión
sí exactamente lo que dice pablo yo
pienso que el marco que marcó una fecha
para mí yo vamos a ceder es podría decir
que si te formales demás yo lo digo yo
creo que ese fue el más grande no sé de
las estadísticas pero para mí si yo
alcancé a ver el personal no alcanzaba
el lugar en la sala de jugadores en los
entrenamientos y pues la verdad que
encima con muchas cosas en el tenis
muchas cosas positivas
en el tenis masculino y también llegó a
impactar el tenis femenino entonces para
mí y obviamente referente al juego ante
la que me termine de contestar la otra
pregunta yo pienso que es una adaptación
que él hizo bastante fuerte porque él
empezó jugando de fondo y éste terminó
jugando un poco más agresivo porque
precisamente el tenis físicamente ahí
revolucionando entonces a él le tocó
irse adaptando a esto y le tocó ser un
saco
con más tiros va a aguantar si el punto
pero tratar de definirlo lo que más
tuvieran la malla entonces como una
adaptación que despertó estas ingestas
de de fácil pero no no es tan fácil
haber ganado los primeros dos partidos
los ganaba muy fáciles empezamos a ver
al principio eran fáciles las primeras
rondas en los gran slam y después
empezaron a verse partidos mucho más
reñidos donde le tocaba subir mucho más
su nivel de juego y su nivel de
concentración bueno catalina y ustedes
estaba diciendo en esta misma respuesta
que marcó muchísimas pautas puede ver
tanto para el juego masculino como para
el juego femenino y aquí le quiero
preguntar pues le quiero pedir más bien
que nos amplíe cuáles son esas pautas
cuáles son esos impactos que usted como
tenista profesional ha visto para sí
misma a lo largo de su carrera
bueno puede ver en el tenis femenino
pues a veces hay mucha rivalidad
pues sí hemos tenido unas grandes
figuras pero pero lo que está diciendo
pablo es no era una persona que en el
tour le saludaba a la mujer saludaba al
hombre o sea porque a veces del tour
femenino y masculino vive en dos mundos
aparte o sea no no no se trata de
combinar yo diría que desde los horarios
hasta hasta los días de finales no
y entonces qué pasó la ofreció la esposa
pues jugadoras profesionales entonces
claro él por ejemplo si uno es preso
tenía la cancha estaba entrenando y
llegaba él a veces a los hombres les
molesta ver que hay una mujer entrenando
y él llegaba y él antes si necesitaba
dejarle más tiempo aún no le dejaba
entonces fue mostrarle eso al tenis
femenino de que después se puede jugar
un buen tenis puede ser agresivo en la
cancha pero por fuera también puede ser
amable con los demás que nunca llegó en
el minuto de ninguna manera como
arrogante como pues como una forma
prepotente yo siempre lo dije siempre lo
he dicho que quería la persona que no
supiera el tenis llegaba a un torneo
donde estuviera a federer y nunca iba a
pensar que era el número uno de la
manera como como se saludaba a los que
estaban en la puerta a los del
restaurante o sea siempre fue muy amable
vuelvo y lo digo muy amable con los
demás y esto yo creo que no eres lo
vimos y yo sé que marcó mucho al tenis
femenino y después tuvimos referencias
que también fueron similar a lo que a lo
que yo pero bueno y ahí a propósito de
eso y de esta relación que usted destaca
con las mujeres pues una de las grandes
de las muy grandes la serena williams
también aprovechó para emitir una
despedida y para expresar esa gran
admiración es que siente y esa
inspiración que sintió a lo largo de su
carrera gracias a roger federer
podríamos hablar de esto también porque
es que no solamente se va a federer
porque semanas antes ya serena williams
nos estaba anunciando su retiro
y mira que ahora es mejor ver en
instagram digo muchos jugadores
profesionales obviamente algunas amigas
otras conocidas y fue impresionante
porque casi todas
y agradeciéndole a roger
diciendo que gracias que ponga gran
figura que se va entonces e inclusive un
poco más que con serena entonces eso
también me cauto es algo de curiosidad
ver que muchas mujeres profesionales
buenas una halle una carla suárez bueno
muchas jugadoras despidiendo a roger
federer y dándole las gracias por lo que
han tenido por lo que dejó en la cancha
pablo usted nos estaba hablando hace un
momento acerca del cambio de paradigma
que represento roger federer en las
canchas de tenis en ese sentido quiero
preguntarle qué legado deja como tenista
su estilo de juego muy clásico muy
elegante como ha sido descrito en una
era de más rapidez de más agresividad de
poder en la cancha y su apego por la
tradición por ejemplo con wild pendón
y yo creo que el legado de feder como te
decía hace un ratito excede lo deportivo
obviamente que deja dejar una muestra de
lo que puede ser jugar el tema clásico
el de que ya no se juega más
posiblemente feliciano lópez que de los
jugadores que juega a lo que jugaba a
federer en muchos muchos chicos han
crecido los que por ejemplo alcaraz
alcaraz creció con federer en la cima y
lo vio jugar lo vio crecer perdón lo vio
lo vio conquistar wimbledon los grandes
torneos y la imagen está el propio
principal que juega como se jugaba antes
justamente porque lo vio hacer jugar un
tenis
antiguo en la era moderna me parece que
el cambio paradigma va por ese lado
y es es la imagen de un de un ser
mitológico jugando al tenis y siendo lo
más simple posible adentro y afuera de
la cancha recién catalina nos mencionaba
como jugadora profesional lo vio mucho
más de cerca
era un nombre común jugando al tenis con
alguien lo hizo en la historia porque la
realidad que más allá de los resultados
a jugar un tenis
superlativo
y es muy elegante muy elegante hay que
buscar mucho en la historia para
encontrar un jugador que haya jugado con
tanta elegancia y con tanta excelencia
me parece que el mensaje de djokovic por
ejemplo de hoy que llegó 24 horas
después del retiro de federer
ha llevado el deporte a la excelencia y
bueno me parece que la excelencia lo que
resume más la carrera de federer y lo
que significa a nivel imagen mundial
porque el legado de feder más va mucho
más allá de lo que pasa en la cancha
masificó el tenis que mejoró el producto
espectáculo porque el tenis
después de federer
fue una cosa en referencia cosa hay una
etapa de transición en la que muchos
jugadores tocaron el número uno del
mundo roddick ferrer o como sea
federer se va a dominar y a vender el
producto de otro modo el negocio creció
el tenis creció el tenis avanzo y eso es
lo que deja para las siguientes
generaciones y bueno la rivalidad con
djokovic es una cosa pero también está
una rivalidad muy especial muy admirada
y muy comentada en la historia del paso
de roger federer por las canchas y es
esa que sostuvo con rafa nadal que por
cierto también fue de los primeros en
reaccionar cuando se conoció la noticia
de la salida del circuito de roger
federer
sí sí lógicamente por más que hayas
jugado muchos más partidos de djokovic y
nadal
me parece que la rivalidad que cambió la
historia del tenis también además de ser
en sí mismo fue la rivalidad que
construyó con nadal sobre todo porque lo
que más llamó la atención en los
primeros años de esa rivalidad fue el
choque de estilos y la elegancia contra
la fuerza la excelencia contra el
sacrificio si se quiere en aquel nadal
también era un jugador que defendía muy
bien
corría muchísimo más que antes que ahora
lógicamente
y ese choque de estilos marcó una época
y eso fue que me parece también lo que
se llamó muchísima atención de gente que
por ahí no no era el tenis pero se
sintió muy atraída por esas situaciones
por esa época
y esa gente gracias a ellos dos a
federal primero después a los dos se
quedaron en el tenis ahora esa misma
gente que llegó al técnico en ellos es
la gente que se queda ahora viendo
alcaraz que posiblemente dominar el
mundo como como lo domino federer en un
momento me parece que en ese sentido esa
rivalidad también jugó a favor del
crecimiento del tenis a nivel
globalización una cara que además se
lamenta muchísimo de no haber se puede
enfrentar a federer de manera
profesional fue catalina no su opinión
es sobre esta gran tripleta que dominó
por tanto tiempo el mundo del tenis
masculino
y esto fue una rivalidad muy
muy agradable de verla entre nadal y
y djokovic y creo que eso es para el
mundo del espectáculo el tenis fue algo
sensacional
porque uno siempre que veía los gran
slam era bueno es quien va a ganar el
gran slam entre entre los tres
siempre era como esa como esta duda y yo
creo que que cada uno es marcó su estilo
federer en pekín manera como suizo como
bien puesto en su sitio nadal como muy
español muy guerrero en la cancha un
djokovic
pues como a veces de un poco con en
problemas pero al mismo tiempo pues
guerrero a no dejarse como como buen
serbio a no dejar entonces eso pues como
muy muy cultural esa rivalidad pero muy
marcada en él cuando se enfrentaban y
muy agradable de ver usar la verdad que
los partidos de ellos eran
y alquilar balcón como se dice eran
demasiado interesantes y creo que les
queda alta generación pues obviamente
djokovic y nadal siguen vigente pero les
queda a los que están viniendo con una
rivalidad como como la o el 3 del 31 y
ya no es lo mismo catalina ahora viene
la ley ver cup el torneo que él mismo
creó un nuevo torneo que le hace honra a
la historia del tenis y aquí pues será
su última participación profesional
algunos lamentan mucho que no alcanzó a
llegar hasta wimbledon
y yo pienso que
yo pienso que lo tuvo que analizar muy
bien creo que
si le preguntan creo que no que no
hubiera querido retirarse ahora pero
pensaría que las dolencias presentan los
dos lesiones creo que fueron los que le
empujaron a tomar esa decisión pensar
como tan rápido entre comillas y no
alcanzar a wimbledon entonces yo crearía
que si hay le preguntan no no no lo
quería además también pensaría que por
la parte familiar dice que también
quiere compartir un poco más con su
familia inclusive ya en años anteriores
aparte de las lesiones también decía que
estaba compartiendo con sus hijos con su
esposa entonces pues yo creo que fue la
combinación yo creo que ya llega un
momento en que en que ya le las
prioridades son otras en la vida por lo
que podemos esperar ver para lo que
sigue que esa es la ley ver cap que
federer vamos a encontrarnos allí
y yo creo que nos vamos a encontrar
mujer
más más del lado del espectáculo y del
lado emocional
hay que decirlo es el último torneo de
federer y por más que seas un torneo de
su propiedad es
va a ser la despedida de posiblemente
uno de los más grandes de toda la
historia el mundo va a estar posando sus
ojos sobre ese torneo por más que sea
una exhibición y no sea un torneo
oficial del circuito va a ser muy
importante verlo sobre todo porque va a
compartir equipo con murray con djokovic
y con nadal va a ser va a ser
emocionante es por ese sentido y lo
tenístico seguramente veremos un cumple
un poco más disminuido un federer un
poco más
jugando a la exhibición
jugando a ganar sí pero pero a cuidarse
también porque es el final y tratará de
dar lo mejor teniendo cuenta que es una
despedida y que su pierna obviamente ya
no dio lo que tenía que dar ese es un
lamento obviamente que no haya llegado
en wimbledon seguramente lo pensó
muchísimo
porque bueno la imagen que dejó además
el año pasado en wimbledon
el último partido con el polaco lukasz
fue fue bastante triste en ese sentido
el último set lo dejó muy disminuido
físicamente y bueno habrá sido ese
partido el último oficial de federer
pero bueno tiene la posibilidad de dejar
una imagen más emocional y más de
alegría en la ley ver acá en londres una
ciudad que también la trajo muchas
alegrías con el másters en ganarlo
tantas veces a fin de año pues muy
importante también para la carrera de él
así que esperaremos que sea una fiesta
que sea un momento del tenis y que sea
un momento que el mundo esté
bueno pueblo y entonces que nos espera a
nosotros los fanáticos por ejemplo yo
que me quedé sin verlo o jugadoras a
nivel profesional podremos ver más de
federer en exhibiciones y en estas giras
que se hacen y que se anularon
lamentablemente en los últimos años por
causa de la pandemia
sí yo creo que sí de hecho en un acto de
la carta en la que anuncia su retiro él
dice voy a hacer el 4 al tenis no voy a
hacerlo más en grand slams y desde
circuitos pero sí voy a seguir cuando al
tenis poco obviamente es una pasión para
federer
yo siempre digo es un jugador un jugador
profesional a ese nivel deseado nunca
jugar a los 40 años como jugó feder si
no hubiera tenido pasión y amor por el
tenis hay muchos tenistas que se queman
mucho más rápido y que terminan
retirándose temprano porque porque
terminan sufriendo ese trajín de los
viajes
sobre todo los americanos porque están
lejos de los puntos neurálgicos del
circuito
pero bueno a mí me parece que va a hacer
eso va a ser un jugador un embajador del
mundo porque va a ser un embajador del
deporte en el mundo cuando exhibiciones
haciendo actividades benéficas como lo
viene haciendo como jugar profesional
ahora lo va a hacer desde afuera y
seguramente tendremos esa imagen de
federer y bueno obviamente alimentante
esa imagen que siempre dejó de la
perfección y de la imagen de que no
tiene ninguna mancha como decía acá
tareas o platos no pero no tiene ningún
tipo de escándalo nada que se le haya
encontrado que pueda arruinar esa imagen
así que seguramente es una pérdida muy
importante para un tenis
catalina cuál es su expectativa de cara
a la ley ver cap
bueno yo pensaría que mucha gente va a
querer ir a verlo como últimamente lo
que dice pablo no pues obviamente se va
a ver un federer no en su tiempo ciento
ya en otra como en otra dinámica
pero pues obviamente va a ser una
sensación mucha creo que va a estar
sobrevendido las las boletas sino ya
está todo me imagino que ya no habrá más
para ir a verlo como la última
y ya que nos estamos acercando al cierre
de este programa y de estos momentos en
los que hemos destacado el juego de
roger federer quisiera catalina a
preguntarle cuáles son esos momentos que
usted tiene más en mente con los logros
más importantes de federer en el tenis
bueno el que más el que más recuerdo es
el partido de wimbledon
contra nadal la final de ese partido fue
sensacional
también pues yo sé que no era una final
pero por ser colombiana fue una emoción
que luego lo hablaba por el alejandro
falla jugar contra federer en wimbledon
que estuvo cerca de ganarle pues para mí
fue algo emocionante
y volver también por el clan santiago
giraldo también jugar contra él pero lo
que más recuerdo ese ese más que nada me
me impactó de acuerdo el partido que
duró horas y que nadie se quería quitar
de la pantalla y pablo de los momentos
que ustedes deja para la historia con
federer
bueno además de la final de wimbledon
2008 que me marca catalina obviamente
quizá por algunos considerado el mejor
partido de la historia a mí siempre me
quedó la imagen también de la final de
australia del 17 ser lesionado en la
pierna izquierda
en este caso seis meses sin jugar y el
primer torneo oficial que juega es
australia en el 17 y gana su primer gran
slam después de cinco años en una final
antológica contra la nada al final de
cinco sets que nos hizo saltar decisions
obviamente un nivel astrológico
me parece que esa es la otra final que
queda muy grabadas la retina de los
fanáticos y bueno obviamente como
argentino tengo que destacar la primera
rivalidad que tuvo con nalbandian que
empezó de su etapa de juveniles porque
son contemporáneos y bueno luego luego
lo que él construyó en esos partidos
épicos con del potro final de grand slam
finales de máster
la verdad que ahí hay otra rivalidad muy
buena para para destacar y bueno ha
jugado con todos
a todos se ha reinventado para para
vencer a los mejores y es la imagen que
queda de feder en un hombre que
trascendió las generaciones dejó un
mensaje al mundo y hizo crecer al tenis
esa es la realidad gracias pablo
catalina sus conclusiones
bueno despedimos
ayer su enviado es triste para el tenis
en el mundo del tenis puedes pedir a un
grande pero una gran una gran gracias
nada una gratitud enorme hacia a roger
federer por tanto que nos dejó que al
tenis
y la última pregunta para despedirlo soy
pablo bueno como ve usted la perspectiva
del tenis es de aquí en adelante ya
definitivamente sin la presencia de
federer
bueno yo lo que vislumbró en el tenis va
a ser una disputa más relacionada a lo
que era tenis antes de federer
que lo que fue hacemos hace 15 años
me parece que se va a repartir mucho más
en la disputa va a estar ahí peleando
alcaraz obviamente con la supremacía que
va a tener si no pasa nada raro y los
jugadores como sí pero como aussel a él
sin
jugadores más jóvenes también
conviviendo con la generación anterior
que la de pérez de hachís y pass la de
2000 kim y si es que puede volver a su
mejor nivel
creo que va a ser un
circuito más más repartido no va a haber
jugadores que ganen 20 grand slams eso
está clarísimo eso no se va a repetir en
la historia pero si vemos que se van a
repartir
los títulos grandes con un poquito más
de pelea por el lado de alcaraz parece
que alcaraz tienes un uno tiene un juego
más interior que los demás y ahí me
parece que va a marcar una diferencia
importante
pues viene hemos llegado al final de
este programa el retiro de su majestad
de roger federer del mundo del tenis en
el circuito profesional gracias a
nuestros invitados por estar con
nosotros y a nuestros televidentes sigan
en france24 nos vemos próximamente
[Música]